[Music]
[Music]
so yes I can we have a small problem we
are and I warned the powers-that-be
about this but we are currently because
you guys have elected to you have put me
in this position we are standing in
CNN's shop
okay does that work for you cat
[Music]
these are you okay
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
kind of
yes
by the fact that he is hoping this
person is a scientist from this disease
and seriously it could impact his
presidency so we expect the next few
minutes ago these apocalypse planets and
that's I can go
[Laughter]
and
I've never seen
yes
task forces and of course the big
question is
[Music]
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much before I begin I'd like to
extend my deepest condolences to the
victims and families in Milwaukee
Wisconsin earlier today a wicked
murderer opened fire at a Molson Coors
Brewing Company plant taking the lives
of five people number of people were
wounded some badly wounded our hearts
break for them and their loved ones we
send our condolences we'll be with them
and it's a terrible thing terrible thing
so our hearts go out to the people of
Wisconsin and to the families thank you
very much
I've just received another briefing from
a great group of talented people on the
virus that is going around to various
parts of the world we have through some
very good early decisions decisions that
were actually ridiculed at the beginning
we closed up our borders to flights
coming in from certain areas areas that
were hit by the corona virus and hit
pretty hard and we did it very early a
lot of people thought we shouldn't have
done it that early and we did and it
turned out to be a very good thing and
the number one priority from our
standpoint is the health and safety of
the American people and that's the way I
viewed it when I made that decision
because of all we've done the risk to
the American people remains very low and
we have the greatest experts in the war
really in the world right here the
people that are called upon by other
countries when things like this happen
we were ready to adapt and we're ready
to do whatever we have to as the disease
spreads if it spreads as most of you
know the the level that we've had in our
country is very low and those people are
getting better or we think that in
almost all cases they're the better are
getting we have a total of 15
we took in some from Japan you heard
about that because they're American
citizens and they're in quarantine
and they're getting better too but we
felt we had an obligation to do that it
could have been as many as 42 and we
found that we were it was just an
obligation we felt that we had we could
have left them and that would have been
very bad very bad I think American
people and they're recovering of the 15
people the original 15 as I call them
eight of them have returned to their
homes to stay in the homes until fully
recovered one is in the hospital and
five have fully recovered and one is we
think in pretty good shape and it's in
between hospital and going home so we
have a total of but we have a total of
15 people and they're in a process of
recovering with some already having
fully recovered we started out by
looking at certain things we've been
working with the hill very very
carefully very strongly and I think we
have very good bipartisan spirit for
money we were asking for two and a half
million and we think that's a lot but
the Democrats and I guess Senator
Schumer wants us to have much more than
that and normally in life I'd say we'll
take it we'll take it if they want to
give more we'll do more we're going to
spend whatever is appropriate hopefully
we're not gonna have to spend so much
because we really think we've done a
great job in keeping it down to a
minimum
and again we've had tremendous success
tremendous success beyond what people
would have thought now at the same time
you do have some outbreaks in some
countries Italy and various countries
are having some difficulty china you
know about where it started I spoke with
President Xi we had a great talk he's
working very hard I have to say
he's working very very hard and if you
can count on the reports coming out of
China that spread has gone down quite a
bit the infection seems to have come
down over the last two days as opposed
to getting larger it's actually gotten
smaller in a one instance where we think
we can be it's somewhat reliable it
seems to have gotten quite a bit smaller
with respect to the money that's being
negotiated they can do whatever they
want I mean they can we'll do the two
and have we're requesting two and a half
some Republicans would like us to get
four and some Democrats would like us to
get eight and a half and we'll be
satisfied whatever whatever it is we're
bringing in a specialist very highly
regarded specialist tomorrow who works
actually at the State Department
very very tremendously talented in doing
this I want you to understand something
that shocked me when I saw that I spoke
with dr. Fauci on this and I was really
amazed and I think most people are
amazed to hear it the flu in our country
kills from 25,000 people to 69 thousand
people a year that was shocking to me
and so far if you look at what we have
with the 15 people and they're
recovering one is one is pretty sick but
hopefully will recover but the others
are in great shape but think of that
25,000 to 69 thousand over the last 10
years we've lost 360,000 these are
people that have died from the flu from
what we call the flu hey did you get
your flu shot and that's something now
what we've done is we've stopped non-us
citizens from coming into America from
China that was done very early on we're
screening people and we have been at a
very high level screening people coming
into the country from infected areas we
have in quarantine those infected and
those at
we have a lot of great quarantine
facilities we're rapidly developing
vaccine and they can speak to you the
professionals can speak to you about
that
the vaccine is coming along well and
then speaking to the doctors we think
this is something that we can develop
fairly rapidly a vaccine for the future
and coordinate with the support of our
partners we have great relationships
with all of the countries that were
talking about some fairly large number
of countries some it's one person and
many countries have no problem
whatsoever and we'll see what happens
but we're very very ready for this for
anything whether it's going to be a
breakout of larger proportions or
whether or not we're you know we're at
that very low level and we want to keep
it that way so we're at the low level as
they get better we take them off the
list so that we're going to be pretty
soon at only five people and we could be
at just one or two people over the next
short period of time
so we've had very good luck the Johns
Hopkins I guess it is a highly respected
great place they did a study
comprehensive the country's best and
worse prepared for an epidemic and the
United States is now were rated number
one we're rated number one for being
prepared this is a list of different
countries I don't want to get in your
way especially since you do such a good
job this is a list of the different
countries United States is rated number
one most prepared United Kingdom
Netherlands Australia Canada Thailand
Sweden Denmark South Korea Finland these
this is a list of of the best rated
countries in the world by Johns Hopkins
we're doing something else that's
important to me because he's been
terrific in many ways but he's also very
good on health care and we really
followed him very closely a lot of
states do when Mike was Governor Mike
Pence
of Indiana they've established great
healthcare they have a great system
their system that a lot of a lot of the
other states have really looked to and
changed their systems they wanted to
base it on the Indiana system he's very
good and I think and he's really very
expert at the field and what I've done
is I'm going to be announcing exactly
right now that I'm gonna be putting our
vice-president Mike Pence in charge and
Mike will be working with the
professionals and doctors and everybody
else that's working the team is is
brilliant I spent a lot of time with the
team over the last couple of weeks but
they're totally brilliant and we're
doing really well and mike is gonna be
in charge and Mike will report back to
me but he's got a certain talent for
this and I'm gonna ask Mike Pence to say
a few words please thank you
Thank You mr. president president
Trump's made clear from the first days
of this administration we have no higher
priority than the safety security health
and well-being of the American people
and from the first word of a outbreak of
the corona virus the president took
unprecedented steps to protect the
American people from the spread of this
disease you've counted those briefly but
the establishment of travel restrictions
aggressive quarantine effort of
Americans that are returning declaration
of a public health emergency and
establishing the White House Corona task
force are all reflective of the urgency
that the president has brought to a
whole-of-government approach as a former
governor from the state where the first
MERS case emerged in 2014 I know full
well the importance of presidential
leadership the importance of
administration leadership and the vital
role of partnerships of state and local
governments and health authorities in
responding to the potential threat of
dangerous infectious diseases and I
I look forward mr. president to serving
in this role I'm bringing together all
the members of the corona task force
that you've established HHS CDC DHS the
Department of Transportation and state
this team has been at your direction mr.
president meeting every day since it was
established my role will be to continue
to bring that team together to bring to
the president the best options for
action to see to the safety and
well-being and health the American
people will also be continuing to reach
out to governor's state and local
officials in fact in the recent days the
White House met with over 40 state
county and city health officials from
over 30 states and territories to
discuss how to respond to this to the
potential threat of the corona virus
we'll be working with them in renewed
ways to make sure they have the
resources to be able to respond and as
the president said we'll be adding
additional personnel here at the White
House to support our efforts on the
president's behalf we'll also be working
with members of Congress to ensure that
the resources are available for this
whole of government response and we'll
be working very closely with secretary
azar and his team that have done an
outstanding job communicating to the
public to ensure the American people I
have the best information on ways to
protect themselves and their families
and also that the public has the most
timely information on the potential
threat to the American people mr.
president as as we've been briefed while
the threat to the American public
remains low of a spread of the corona
virus you have directed this team to
take all steps necessary to continue to
ensure the health and well-being of the
American people and the people of this
country can be confident that under your
leadership we will continue to bring the
full resources of the federal government
in coordination with our state and local
partners to see today
health and well-being into the effective
response to the coronavirus here in the
United States of America with that the
president has asked me to recognize the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Alex a czar and also the deputy director
CDC a doctor an Chaka for Vermonters
well thank you mr. vice president and
Thank You mr. president for gathering
your public health experts here today
and for your strong leadership in
keeping America safe and I just want to
say I could not be more delighted that
you've asked the vice president my old
friend and colleague to lead this whole
of government approach with us under the
emergency support function number eight
as of today we have 15 cases of kovat 19
that have been detected in the United
States with only one new case detected
in the last two weeks we also have three
cases among Americans repatriated from
Wuhan and forty two cases among
Americans repatriated who had been stuck
on the diamond princess in Japan the
president's early and decisive actions
including travel restrictions have
succeeded in buying US incredibly
valuable time this has helped us contain
the spread of the virus handle the cases
that we have and prepare for the
possibility that we will need to
mitigate broader spread of infections
within the United States the president's
actions taken with the strong support of
his scientific advisors have proven to
be appropriate wise and well calibrated
to the situation we're grateful for the
hard work that health care workers first
responders communities state and local
leaders have put into the response so
far because of this hard work and the
president's leadership the immediate
risk to the American public has been and
continues to be low our containment
strategy has been working at the same
time what every one of our experts and
leaders have been saying for more than a
month now remains true the degree of
risk has the potential to change quickly
and we can expect to see more cases in
the United States that is why we've been
reminding the American public in our
state local
and private-sector partners that they
should be aware of what a broader
response would look like CDC has
recommended that the American public and
especially state and local governments
businesses and other organizations
should refresh themselves on how they
would respond in the event that the
situation worsens
we're encouraging Americans to learn
what future steps might be necessary to
keep themselves in their communities
safe knowing these potential steps now
can help keep the risk to you in your
community low Americans can find useful
information at cdc.gov
/ko vyd co VI d 19 and we're working
closely with government and private
sector partners to educate them about
preparedness finally we've begun working
with Congress to secure the funding that
we need there are five major priorities
in the White House request to Congress
that the White House made on Monday
these priorities are first expanding our
surveillance network second support for
state and local governments work third
and fourth development of therapeutics
and vaccines and fifth manufacturing and
purchase of personal protective
equipment like gowns and masks as
chairman of the president's coronavirus
task force I'm committed to providing
regular updates from our coordinated
interagency process we've had our top
public health leaders like those joining
me here today speaking to the media many
times per day to inform the American
public the Trump administration is going
to continue to be aggressively
transparent keeping the American people
and the media apprised of the situation
and what everyone can do with that I'm
going to hand things over to dr. and
shook it doctor shook it is the senior
career official at the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention the
principal deputy director with an over
30 year career at the CDC in public
health and as a member of the United
States Public Health Service
commissioned Corps
so dr. shooked I'll turn it over to you
thanks so much mr. secretary as you know
this has been a difficult and
challenging time
our hearts go out to the individuals who
have been directly affected by the virus
and to all those who have been working
tirelessly in responding to it our
aggressive containment strategy here in
the United States has been working and
is responsible for the low levels of
cases that we have so far however we do
expect more cases and this is a good
time to prepare
we as you heard it's the perfect time
for businesses health care systems
universities and schools to look at
their pandemic preparedness plans dust
them off and make sure that they're
ready and we have lots more information
at the CDC's website and in partnership
on how to do that but it's also a really
good time for the American public to
prepare and for you to know what this
means for you
the coronavirus that we're talking about
is a respiratory virus it's spread in a
similar way to the common cold or to
influenza it's spread through coughs and
sneezes and so those everyday sensible
measures that we tell people to do every
year with the flu are important here
covering your cough staying home when
you're sick and washing your hands
tried-and-true not very exciting
measures but really important ways that
you can prevent the spread of
respiratory viruses so this the
trajectory of what we're looking at over
the weeks and months ahead is very
uncertain but many of the steps that we
have taken over the past 15 years to
prepare for pandemic influenza and our
experience going through the 2009 h1n1
pandemic of influenza remind us of the
kinds of steps that our healthcare
system our businesses our communities of
schools may need to take we're in this
together all of government the public
and the private sector and the CDC wants
to make sure you have the best
information available
every day thank you I just want to give
you a very quick update on the my name
is uh dr. Tony Fauci I'm the director of
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases at NIH
just a very quick update on the
countermeasure development in the form
of vaccines and therapeutics I had told
this audience at a recent press briefing
that we have a number of vaccine
candidates and one prototype one to give
you a feel for the time frame of a
vaccine and what its impact might be now
and in subsequent years is that I told
you we would have a vaccine that we
would be putting into trials to see if
it's safe and if it induces a response
that you would predict would be
protective in about three months I think
it's gonna be a little bit less than
that it's probably gonna be closer to
two months that would then take about
three months to determine if it's safe
and immuno genic which gives us six
months then you graduate from a trial
which is phase one of 45 people to a
trial that involves hundreds if not lo
thousands of people to determine
efficacy at the earliest and efficacy
trial would take an additional six to
eight months so although this is the
fastest we have ever gone from a
sequence of a virus to a trial it still
will not be any applicable to the
epidemic
unless we'd really wait about a year to
a year and a half now that means two
things one the answer to containing is
public health measures we can't rely in
a vaccine over the next several months
to a year however if this virus which we
have every reason to believe it is quite
conceivable that it will happen will go
beyond just a season and come back and
recycle next year if that's the case we
hope to have a vaccine and then finally
in briefly therapeutics there are a
number of antiviral drugs that are being
tested a few days ago we initiated a
randomized controlled trial of a drug
quorum death severe which has antiviral
activity
vitro in an animal model the good news
about that is that it's a trial that's
randomized to either placebo or standard
of care and drug and standard of care
which means that we will know reasonably
soon whether it works and if it does we
will then have an effective therapy to
distribute we won't talk so much just
got back off like so ones like he's a
great gentleman a great leader
it's an incredible country we were
treated very very well and we were
really enjoyed it a lot of tremendous
progress was made in terms of
relationship our relationship with India
is extraordinary right now and we're
gonna be doing a lot of business with
India they're sending billions and
billions of dollars now to the United
States but would rather talk about this
right now
CDC said yesterday that they believe
it's inevitable that the virus will
spread in the United States and it's not
a question of if but when do you agree
with that assessment well I don't think
it's inevitable I probably will it
possibly will it could be at a very
small level there could be at a larger
level what whatever happens we're
totally prepared we have the best people
in the world you see that from the study
we have the best prepared people the
best people in the world Congress is
willing to give us much more than we're
even asking for it's nice for a change
but we are totally ready willing and
able it's a term that we use it's ready
willing and able we have we have it's
gonna be very well under control now it
may get bigger and make it a little
bigger it may not get bigger at all
we'll see what happens but regardless of
what happens we're totally prepared
please thank you talking earlier about
the Supreme acres that you put in place
them into travel with stretches you can
place for burning China at this point
has the virus present Italy South Korea
are you planning on having those
countries well Justin you know I'm the
president of the United States I'm not
the president of other countries other
countries some on the list that are very
respected in what they do in terms of
what we're talking about but I really
want to be responsible for this country
if it means placing very strong very
strong situation on the border so people
can't come into our country from a
country that is infected that's we're
doing that we've already done it with
numerous countries but we have to focus
on this country I don't think it's right
to impose ourselves on others but if
others aren't taking care or we think
they're doing it incorrectly you know
we're dealing with world health and we
have terrific people and CDC does go
around and help other countries give
them recommendations as what to do but
they're working on their countries that
we're working on our countries and so
far from our simple one it's really
worked out very well
can you clarify are you considering
restricting travel to and from South
Korea Italy and other kind
at a right time we may do it right now
it's not the right time but at the right
time and we are checking people as they
come through specifically for the
problem the problem that we're dealing
with so we're checking a lot of people
over there coming from South Korea's
been hit pretty hard
Italy's been in pretty hard China is
obvious what's happened in China but
again the numbers seem to be leveling
off and going down in China which is
very good news so we'll see what happens
they are going to a point of the SAR to
run point on the coronavirus response
today the secretary Hayes R testified
that he didn't think one was necessary
they were going to run it out of HHS and
you yourself have been downplaying this
so why are you now selecting the vice
president his vice president he's in the
administration but I'm having everybody
report to Mike Mike's been very good
very adept anybody that knows anything
about health care they look at the
Indiana model and it's been a very great
success it's been a tremendous model in
terms of healthcare and this is really
an offshoot of that so this is an azure
I don't view my kisses are Mike as part
of the administration but I'm having
them report to Mike Mike will report to
me they'll also be reporting in some
cases to both I'll be going to meetings
quite a bit depending on what they want
to do and what message we want to get
out but we've done really an
extraordinary job when you look at a
country this size with so many people
pouring in with the number one in the
world for people coming into a country
by far and we have a total of 15 cases
many of which almost much within a day
out I will tell you most of whom are
fully recovered I think that's really a
pretty impressive mark now we did take
in 40 people that were Americans and
they were also recovering but we brought
them in so I call that I have a
different group but we felt we had an
obligation to American citizens outside
of the country that we're trying to get
back in we thought it was very market
has taken a big hit over the last few
days what can you do about that and if
the CDC is right in saying that the
spread is inevitable are you going to be
dealing with stock market issues and
economy issues for some time well I
really think the stock market if
something I know a lot about I think it
took a hit maybe for two reasons I think
they look at the people that you watched
debating last night and they say if
there's even a possibility that can
happen I think it really takes a hit
because of that and it certainly took a
hit because of this and I understand
that also because of supply chains and
various other things and people coming
in but I think the stock market will
recover the economy is very strong that
a consumer is the strongest it's ever
been or consumers are incredible they're
an incredible that's why we're doing
well in other countries have not even
before the virus we're doing great
other countries have not been doing
great a consumers very very strong very
powerful economically any plan that
would involve quarantine cities like we
saw in China and what would have to
happen for you to take we don't have
plans of a much or much larger scale
should we need that we're working with
states we're working with virtually
every state and we do have plans on a
larger scale if we need it we don't
think we're going to need it but you
know you always have to be prepared and
again Congress is talking to us about
funding and we're getting far more than
what we asked for and I guess the best
thing to do is take it we'll take it are
you willing to give Congress if they're
going well we're gonna see if it will
take care of states because states are
working very hard we have hospitals and
states that make rooms available and
they they're building quarantine areas
areas where you can keep people safely
we're working really well with states
it's a very big part of it so you know
my attitude if Congress wants to give us
the money so easy wasn't very easy for
the wall but we got that one done if
they want to give us the money and we'll
take the money we'll just do a good job
with it yeah should Americans be going
out getting protective equipment such as
and so forth and if so what is the u.s.
doing to boost production of math well
we can get a lot of it in fact we've
ordered a lot of it just in case we need
it we may not need it you understand
that but in case we're looking at
worst-case scenario we're going to be
set very quickly but we I don't think
we're gonna ever be anywhere near that I
really don't believe that we're gonna be
anywhere near that our borders are very
controlled our flights in from certain
areas that we're talking about a very
controlled I don't think we'll ever be
anywhere near that please go back to the
stock market for a second the travel
related stocks have especially been yeah
Amer here in the last couple days what
would you say to Americans out there who
right now are looking forward to the
summer or the upcoming months and saying
to themselves
should I make myself summer plans should
I go travel abroad well hopefully
they're gonna be able to do that we
think we hope that it's gonna be in good
shape by that time but you know they're
gonna have to remain a little bit
flexible yeah I would say travel related
companies certainly right now that would
be that would be they would be hurt at
the same time this ends this is gonna
end hopefully it'll be sooner rather
than later and I think the business that
they lost will be picked up at a later
date but you know right now I think
they're not gonna be probably not going
to be going to China they're not going
to be going to certain countries where
the problem is far greater than it is in
the United States what it's going to do
is keep people home and they're going to
travel to places that we have we have
the greatest it's the greatest tourism
country in the world so instead of
leaving our country leaving our shores
they'll stay here and again when you
have 15 people and the 15 within a
couple of days is going to be down to
close to zero that's a pretty good job
we've done
what is your response to speaker
Philippines that earlier today you don't
know what you're talking about about the
corona virus wasn't wondering if you
want to address pretty soon well I sure
what your administration sure I think
speaker Pelosi is incompetent
she lost the Congress once I think she's
gonna lose it again she lifted my poll
numbers up ten points I never thought
that I would see that so quickly and so
easily I'm leading everybody we're doing
great
I don't want to do it that way it's
almost unfair if you think about it but
I think she's incompetent and I think
she's not thinking about the country and
instead of making a statement like that
where I've been beating her routinely at
everything
instead of making a statement like that
she should be saying we have to work
together because we have a big problem
potentially and maybe it's going to be a
very little problem I hope that it's
going to be a very little problem but we
have to work together instead she wants
to do that same thing with Brian Chuck
Schumer he goes out and he says the
president only asked for two and a half
billion dollars he should have eight and
a half if this is the first time I've
ever been told that we should take more
usually it's we have to take less and we
should be working together he shouldn't
be making statements like that because
it's so bad for the country and Nancy
Pelosi I mean she should go back to a
district and clean it up because it's a
number one if you look at percentage
down that was one of the finest in the
world and now you look at what's
happening and I'm just saying we should
all be working together she's trying to
create a panic and there's no reason to
panic because we have done so good these
professionals behind me and over here
and over there and back here and in some
conference rooms I just left a group of
45 people that are the most talented
people in the world parts of the world
are asking us in a very nice way can
they partake and help them so Nancy
Pelosi shouldn't and she knows it's not
true she knows all all they're trying to
do is get a political advantage
this isn't about political advantage
we're all trying to do the right thing
they shouldn't be saying this is
terrible president Trump isn't asking
for enough money how stupid a thing to
say if they want to give us more money
that's okay we'll take more money some
Republicans think we should have more
money - that's okay we'll take more
money but they shouldn't do me
the people that are on the stage who are
the finest in the world they're not
demeaning me they're demeaning the
greatest health care professionals in
the world and people that do exactly
what we're talking about your campaign
today sue the New York Times for an
opinion piece yeah is it your opinion or
is it your contention that if people
have an opinion contrary to yours that
they should be sued well when they get
the opinion totally wrong as the New
York Times did and frankly they've got a
lot wrong over the last number of years
so we'll see how that let that work its
way through the court if you'll see it's
beyond an opinion that's not an opinion
that's something much more than an
opinion they did a bad thing
and they'll be more coming Tokio way to
posture right do you expect what can we
be I hope so because shinzo obvious a
very good friend of mine I love the
people of Japan and I hope it's gonna be
in good shape as you know you have a
number of people in Japan who have been
infected I hear they're doing a very
professional job which doesn't surprise
me at all
with Shinzo and with all of the people
you have I know Japan very well I think
they're gonna handle it very well
it's a little tight you know it's a
little tight they spent billions of
dollars building one of the most
beautiful venues I've ever seen and your
Prime Minister is very proud of it I
hope it's going to be fine we hope it
will
[Applause]
very much president the doctor at CDC
just talked about dusting off
preparedness plans but coming from you
and it has more weight do you feel that
US schools should be preparing for a
corona virus right I would think so yes
I mean I haven't spoken specifically
about that with the various doctors but
I would think so yes I think every
aspect of our society should be prepared
I don't think it's going to come to that
especially with the fact that we're
going down not up we're going very
substantially down not up but yeah I
think school should be preparing and you
know get ready just in case the words
are just in case we don't think we're
going to be there we don't think we're
gonna be anywhere close and again if you
look at some countries they are coming
down it's starting to go in the other
direction
this will end this will end you look at
flu season I said 26,000 people I've
never heard of a number like that 26,000
people going up to sixty nine thousand
people doctor you tell me before 69
thousand people die every year from 26
to 69 every year from the flu now think
of that it's incredible so far the
results of all of this that everybody's
reading about and and part of the thing
is you you want to keep it the way it is
you don't want to see panic because
there's no reason to be panicked in bed
but when I mentioned the flu I said
actually I asked the various doctors I
said is this just like flu because
people died from the flu and this is
very unusual and it is a little bit
different but in some ways it's easier
and in some ways it's a little bit
tougher but we have it so well under
control I mean we really have done a
very good job
you mentioned the stock market earlier
to go back to that to be clear the Dow
Jones dropped more than 2000 points this
week are you suggesting that that was
overblown our financial markets
overreacting here I think the financial
markets are very upset when they look at
the Democrat candidates standing on that
stage making fools out of themselves and
they say if we ever have a president
like this and there's always a
possibility it's an election you know
who knows what happens right I think
we're gonna win I think we're gonna win
by a lot but when they look at the
statements made by the people stand
beyond
standing behind those podiums I think
that has a huge effect you have to do
with the chronic well I think it did I
think it did but I think you can add
quite a bit of sell-off to what they're
saying because they're seeing the
potential you know again I think we're
gonna win I feel very confident of it
we've done everything and much more than
I said we were going to do you look at
what we've done what we've done is
incredible with the tax cuts and
regulation cuts and rebuilding our
military taking care of our vets and
getting them choice and accountability
all of the things we've done protecting
our Second Amendment I mean they view
that the Second Amendment is they were
they're going to destroy the Second
Amendment when people look at that they
say this is not good so you add that in
I really believe that's a factor but no
this is what we're talking about is is
the virus that's what we're talking
about I do believe that's I do believe
in terms of CNBC and in terms of Fox
Business I do believe that that's a
factor yeah and I think after I win the
election I think the stock market is
going to boom like it's never bloomed
before just like it did by the way after
I won the last election the stock market
the day after went up like a rocket ship
we're not going to loosen the travel
restrictions that's what saved us had I
not made Mike alluded to it had I not
made a decision very early on not to
take people from a certain area we
wouldn't be talking this way we'd be
talking about many more people would
have been infected I took a lot of heat
I mean some people call me racist
because I made a decision so early and
we had never done that as a country
before let alone early so it was a you
know bold decision it turned out to be a
good decision but I was criticized by
the Democrats they called me a racist
because I made that decision if you can
believe that one we have to all work
together we can't say bad things and
especially when we have the best team
anywhere in the world and and we really
gave it an early start we gave it a very
early start
consistently called for enormous putts
the CDC the NIH and the whou can lost a
lot today about how these professionals
are excellent under critical and
necessary this experience I'll give you
pause about them now because we we can
get money and we can increase staff we
know all the people we know all the good
people is a question I asked the doctors
before some of the people we cut they
haven't been used for many many years
and if they if we have a need and we can
get them very quickly and rather than
spending the money and I'm a business
person I don't like having thousands of
people around when you don't need them
when we need them we can get them back
very quickly for instance we're bringing
some people in tomorrow that are already
in this you know great government that
we have and very specifically for this
we can build up very very quickly and
we've already done that I mean we really
have built up we have a great staff and
using Mike I'm doing that because he's
in the administration and he's very good
at doing what he does and doing as it
relates to this administration is only
testing a less than 500 people and
health officials are questioning whether
that's enough comparing to other
countries who have tested more than the
tens of thousands of people are you
planning to test more people well we're
testing everybody that we need to test
and we're finding very little problem
very little problem now you treat this
like a flu we were in fact I might ask
one of the doctors to come up and
explain it you want to wash your hands a
lot you want to stay if you're not
feeling well if you feel you have a flu
stay inside sort of quarantine yourself
don't go outside but there are certain
steps that you can take that we won't
even be necessary you know in many cases
when you catch this it's very light you
don't even know there's a problem
sometimes they just get the sniffles
sometimes they just get something where
they're not feeling quite right and
sometimes they feel really bad but
that's a little bit like the flu it's a
little like the regular flu that we have
flu shots for and we'll essentially have
a flu shot for this in a fairly quick
manner yeah go ahead
two weeks ago mr. president you're
acting OMB director was was in this room
and was talking about what he expects to
be GDP growth for this coming year he
said it was 3% and we've talked about
the effects of the corona virus on the
supply chain the declines in the
financial markets are you still
confident that you'll see that kind of
economic growth this no we're gonna have
tremendously low unemployment we're
setting records and that were in fact
the administration as a as you know the
lowest average unemployment of any
Administration in history and our
numbers are very low very good 3.5 3.6
but you can't really see what this does
in terms of GDP it could affect it but
that's irrelevant compared to what we're
talking about we want to make sure it's
safe safety number one but this would
have you know an impact on GDP but we're
still very very we're doing great but
this will have just like I'll tell you
what has a big impact Boeing has a big
impact how did that happen a year ago
all of a sudden that happened I think
that took away a half a point to a point
even you know it's a massive company I
think Boeing we had the General Motors
strike that was a big impact on GDP and
of course we're paying interest rates I
disagree with the head of the Fed I'm
not I'm not happy with what that is
because he's kept interest rates
President Obama didn't have near the
numbers and yet if you look at what
happened he was paying zero we're paying
interest now it's more conservative and
frankly people that put their money away
are now getting a return on that money
as opposed to not getting anything but I
think you know where the with the
greatest of them all we should be paying
the lowest interest rates and when
Germany and other countries are paying
negative rates meaning they're literally
getting paid when they put out money I
mean they they borrow money and they get
paid when this gets paid back who ever
heard of this before it said first but
we don't do that so I totally disagree
with our Fed I think our Fed has made a
terrible mistake and it would have made
a big difference as good as we've done
even without the 2000 points and we
started off at 16,000 and we'll be a
28,000 without we're going to crack
30,000 we have had increases like
nobody's seen before but we're doing
well but
we have to watch we're doing well anyway
in other words even despite the two
thousand points it sounds like a lot and
it's a lot but it's nothing it's very
little compared to what we've gone up
but we'll be watching it very closely
but we have been hurt by General Motors
we've been hurt by Boeing and we've hurt
by we've been hurt in my opinion very
badly by our own Federal Reserve who has
also created a very strong dollar that's
something nice about a strong dollar but
it makes it much harder to do business
outside of this country thank you sir
yeah a number of your supporters online
have embraced these theories or forward
of these theories that the CDC may be
exaggerating the threat of coronavirus
to hurt you politically rush limbaugh
the other day said this has been
advanced to weaponize the virus against
you you don't my supporters you mean my
my people that are not support right
your I think and and I'd like it to stop
I think people know that when Chuck
Schumer gets up said he did the same
thing with a couple of trade deals that
are phenomenal deals now everybody's
acknowledged a phenomenal deals before
he ever saw the day he didn't even know
we were going to make a deal they said
what do you think of the deal with China
I don't like it I don't like it he
talked about tariffs I left the tariffs
on twenty five percent when two hundred
and fifty billion dollars he said he
took the tariffs off he didn't even know
the deal and he was out there knocking
it because that's a natural thing to say
but when you're talking about especially
something like this we have to be on the
same team this is too important we have
to be on the same team the CDC is trying
to hurt you that no I don't think the
CDC is at all know they've been they've
been working really well together
they really are they're professional I
think they beyond that they want this to
go away they want to do it with as
little disruption and and they don't
want to lose life I see the way they're
working there this general these people
behind me and others that are in the
other room they're incredible people no
I don't see that at all thank you
tonight you're minimizing the risk the
danger of the virus are you telling the
Americans except for the ones who are
sick not to change any other therapy of
their behaviors no I think you have to
always I do it a lot anyway as you
probably heard wash your hands stay
clean you don't have to necessarily grab
every handrail unless you have to you
know you do certain things that you do
when you have the flu I mean view this
the same as the flu when somebody
sneezes I mean I try and bailout as much
as possible when they're sneezing I had
a man come up to me a week ago I hadn't
seen him in a long time and I said how
you doing he said fine honey he hugs me
kiss I said are you well he says no he
said I have the worst fever in the worst
flu and he's hugging and kissing me so I
said excuse me I went to southern
watching my so you have to do that you
know this is I really think doctor you
want to treat this like you treat the
flu right and you know it's gonna be
it's gonna be
don't ruin it with a bad question 14
during during the entire crisis you said
you wanted a quote unquote full travel
ban you said Obama was a fourth unquote
stubborn dope not for doing it you said
just stop the flights dummies you also
said it was a quote unquote
total joke to appoint someone to lead
the Ebola response with quote zero
experience in the medical field now you
hope they listen to a lot of what I had
to say I did and they listened to a lot
well because this is a much different
problem than Ebola Ebola you
disintegrated especially at the
beginning they've made a lot of progress
now on Ebola but with Ebola we were
talking about it before you
disintegrated you got Ebola that was it
this one is different much different
this is a flu this is like a flu and
this is a much different situation than
Ebola but and we're working on Ebola
right now by the way we're working on
certain areas of the Congo the Congo has
Ebola and caused largely by the fact
that they have war and people can't get
there we can now treat Ebola in that at
that time it was infectious
and you couldn't treat it nobody knew
anything about it nobody had ever heard
of anything like this so it's a much
different situation
and just the course in the last couple
of minutes you have disputed some of
what the officials their administration
behind you have said about the risk of
crota virus and it's spread do you trust
your health officials to give you good
information Australian stinks I don't
think I have they've said it could be
worse and I've said it could be worse -
are you all something no I don't think
it's inevitable I don't think it's
inevitable I think that we're doing a
really good job in terms of maintaining
borders and turning in terms of letting
people in in terms of checking people
and also that's one of the reasons I'm
here today getting the word out so
people can still know they're gonna know
no I don't think it's I don't think it's
inevitable I think that there's a chance
that it could get worse as a chance you
could get fairly substantially worse but
nothing's inevitable Brazil right Brazil
and you have many Americans now in
Brazil for Carnival what are your
concerns and what are the procedures and
practices that you plan to implement as
those Americans are trying to come back
yes we've got very strong on people
coming in from Brazil now it only has
one case it's a big country but it only
has one case but still it's a case we
deal with Brazil very well the
president's a very good friend of mine
in fact he ran on exactly what's called
make Brazil great again that's what he
ran on we get along very well I know
you're so thrilled to hear that we get
along very very well and we're working
with Brazil but we have much worse
instances than Brazil you know you have
Italy and you have other countries where
they have much more than one person they
have one person right now as of now as
if just a little while ago one person in
Brazil but Italy is you know a deeper
problem and we're checking people coming
in very very strongly from those and at
some point we may cut that off you know
at some point depending on what happens
we may cut certain additional countries
off like we've had to do with China and
we hope we can open it up to China as
soon as possible and we and we hope the
numbers we've been getting we hope the
numbers that we've been getting are true
on China where it really has leveled off
and started to go down because
eventually sometimes that's going to
happen
thank you very much you've said
repeatedly that you think the federal
government is very prepared that you're
ready for this no but if you think that
secretary a czar is doing such a great
job why did you feel the need to make a
change and book vice president Mike
Pence in charge of the federal response
to the spiral because and I think I
think secretary is doing a fantastic job
but he also has many other things I mean
we're working on many many things
together if you look at his schedule of
what he's doing including drug prices
and I think it's perhaps the most
complicated job that we have in
government and I want him to be able to
focus on that and Mike is really good at
it they're going to work together
they're going to work very closely
together and they're both in the
administration I see them all the time
so it really works this is a nazar this
isn't going out and getting somebody
that's never been in the administration
I have two people that are very talented
and it's something I feel good about I
don't want it I don't want to spare the
horses
I have very talented people I want to
use them on this because I wanted to
stay low or as low as possible to China
at the beginning of this outbreak the
Chinese Communist Party covered it up
that has been that has been the general
consensus of everyone how can you now
legitimately trust President Zine and
the Chinese Xiaomi is freaking vision
the fourth coming and fourth right with
this pen well I can tell you this I
speak to him I'd talk with him very
recently and he is working so hard on
this problem he is working so hard and
they're very tough and very smart and
it's a significant it's a significant
group of very talented people that are
working and they're calling up dr.
Falchi they're calling up our people
we're dealing with them we're giving
them certain advice
we actually have through world health we
have them over there also and we have a
lot of our people making up that group
that went over there no he's working
very hard to be very easy for me to say
you know doesn't matter what I say
really I can tell you he is working I
had a long talk with him the other night
he is working really really hard he
wants it to go away from China and go
away fast and he wants to get back to
business as usual
homebuyers who have a fatality ratio of
about 0.1% this has a fatality ratio
somewhere between 3% we don't know
exactly and the flu is higher than that
the flu is much higher than that this is
spreading or it's gonna spread maybe
within communities that's it expectation
does that does that worry you because
I've seen no worries now because we're
ready for it it is what it is we're
ready for it we're really prepared we
have as I said we've had we have the
greatest people in the world we're very
ready for it we hope it doesn't spread
there's a chance that it won't spread to
and there's a chance that it will then
it's a question of at what level so far
we've done a great job when you have 15
people with this whole world coming into
the United States and the 15 people are
either better or close to being better
that's pretty good there's been many
cases of price gouging on the sales of
medical equipment masks and so on should
the government be investigating that by
thinking of a message if you tell me
that's happening we would definitely
investigate we don't want that
specifically in what areas also working
with China we just did the biggest trade
deal in history we did two of them
between us MCA and the China deal it's
the biggest in history the relationship
with China is a very good one and I can
tell you that again President Xi is
working really hard he wants this
problem so as hard as you can work thank
you all thank you
if I could clarify I think you're not
getting a point here of this I'm still
chairman of the task force Mick Mulvaney
has been serving actually an invaluable
role for me as acting chief of staff
helping to coordinate across the
government with my colleagues and the
whole of government approach having the
vice president gives me the biggest
stick one could have in the government
on this whole of government approach not
in the least I'm when the print one when
this was mentioned to me I said I was
delighted that I get to have the vice
president helping them this way
delighted absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]